[Music]
2016 has been a long brutal year for
celebrity deaths in addition to the loss
of renowned musicians such as David
Bowie and Prince many screen stars have
also died this year from cherished
character actors to major movie stars
here is a look back the actors and
actresses who passed away in 2016
Alan Rickman after joining the Royal
Shakespeare Company in England in the
1970s Alan Rickman broke out on the big
screen in 1988 at the relatively
advanced age of 41 but what a
breakthrough role it was playing the
evil Hans Gruber and die hard set in
motion a career of playing some of
Hollywood's most iconic screen villains
such as the Sheriff of Nottingham and
Robin Hood Prince of Thieves Judge
Turpin and Sweeney Todd and the secret
good guy professor Severus Snape in all
eight Harry Potter movies Rickman died
at age 69 after a battle with pancreatic
cancer gene Wilder few would disagree
that Gene Wilder was a comic genius his
collaborations with director Mel Brooks
were especially fruitful spawning his
memorable turns in the producers Blazing
Saddles and Young Frankenstein that's
Frankenstein that would be enough of a
legacy for any actor but Wilder also
played the title role in Willy Wonka and
the Chocolate Factory
and starred in three buddy comedy movies
with Richard Pryor cementing his status
as a true screen legend in August 2016
when Wilder died at the age of 83 from
complications from Alzheimer's disease
his passing was quite unexpected he'd
apparently concealed his condition from
the public because the actor simply
couldn't bear the idea of one less smile
in the world Anton Yelchin this Russian
American actor was just beginning to
emerge as a major young talent earning
critical praise for his work in Green
Room and the Star Trek franchise among
other films but he tragically passed
away at the age of 27 when his vehicle
rolled down his driveway and pinned him
against a brick pillar in a bizarre
accident at his home Peter Vaughn this
tireless character actor was probably
best known to American audiences as
Maester Aemon on Game of Thrones but he
was also an accomplished star of film
and TV for decades before he joined the
HBO fantasy series his standout roles
and British comedies and cult classic
films made of a star in his homeland
before he travelled anywhere
near the wall he was 93 Garry Shandling
one of the most prominent stand-up
comedians in the 1980s and a pioneer of
the observational comedy style Garry
Shandling went on to co-create and
starred two of the most forward-thinking
TV comedies ever made his self-titled
sitcom and his mockumentary style
dramedy the Larry Sanders Show Shandling
would go on to make a formidable
big-screen career for himself too but
it's his TV work which made him a
pop-culture icon before his death at his
home at the age of 66 Alan Thicke
thanks to his memorable turn as the
Seaver family patriarch on TVs growing
pains
Alan Thicke was beloved as a parental
figure for many children of the 80s
Alan Thicke was 69 when he passed
reportedly after playing a game of
hockey with his youngest son Patty Duke
at the age of just 16 Patty Duke became
the youngest-ever Academy Award winner
for her role as Helen Keller in 1962 s
The Miracle Worker
and a year later she began her small
screen turn as identical cousins on the
self-titled Patty Duke show her career
in film television and stage would be
long-lived and she passed on her acting
gene to her son Sean Astin of Lord of
the Rings fan duke was also a vocal
advocate for mental illness awareness
after being diagnosed with bipolar
disorder
she died of sepsis at the age of 69
Garry Marshall while this Hollywood
legend might be best known for his work
behind the lens Garry Marshall was also
a memorable actor in his time his
boisterous personality made its way to
the big screen in hocus pocus and a
league of their own along with a number
of television series Marshall died at
the age of 81 Kenny Baker for Star Wars
fans
Kenny Baker's face wasn't the most
recognizable part of his presence he was
the actor who brought life to r2d2 and
six of the Star Wars films and became an
icon of that franchise before visiting a
galaxy far far away though he was known
for his work as a circus clown and
comedian he was 81 when he passed away
after a long illness
Jon Polito if you've ever seen a Coen
Brothers film chances are you've seen
Jon Polito at his best the long working
character actor appeared in some of the
directors most acclaimed projects all
told
pollito appeared in more than 100 movies
and TV shows over the course of a three
decades long career and was 65 when he
died of
blood cancer Alexis Arquette transgender
actress Alexis Arquette was a prominent
member of her acting family and was
memorable for her big screen roles and
pulp fiction in the wedding singer as
well as her activism for LGBTQ issues
she was 47 when she passed away Robert
Vaughn legendary small screen star
Robert Vaughn thrived for decades in the
action show sphere he is perhaps best
known for his work in the Man From UNCLE
and the a-team Vaughn was also among the
first actors ever to speak out about
political views working with several
anti Vietnam War organizations during
his prime and received a PhD in
communications he was 83 wineglass with
not one but two cult hits on the small
screen bran glass is best known for his
scene-stealing work as sergeant Harrison
Barney Miller but sci-fi fans will
probably know him best for his role as
Shepard book in the short-lived and
beloved series Firefly he was 71
Alice Drummond one of the most
recognizable character actresses of all
time Alice Drummond popped up in dozens
of movies and TV shows since the late
60s when she moved from the New York
stage to the screen one of her most
famous appearances may have been in the
original Ghostbusters but she starred in
dozens of films and TV shows before
passing away at the age of 88
Margaret Witten major-league fans might
remember Margaret Witten best for her
turn as the mean team owner rachel
phelps but in real life she was an avid
fan of the sport the actors worked on
multiple media throughout her career
including movies and the stage and was
67 when she died
Zsa Zsa Gabor a predecessor of Paris
Hilton and Kim Kardashian Zsa Zsa Gabor
pioneered the idea of being famous for
being famous the Hungarian born Gabor
was married at least eight times almost
always to wealthy tycoons of one sort or
another she still managed an acting
career of sorts appearing in films and
TV shows in the 50s and 60s such as the
original Moulin Rouge and as the
seductive Minerva on the campy Batman
after suffering from a series of
illnesses and injuries over the past few
years Gabor passed away at the age of 99
on December 18th thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
you